a lot of news just dropped like there's
a lot of teeth that we got to talk about
so it's not too late is what you're
saying it's definitely not too late in
fact on YouTube I would say it's early
because of a few things that are
happening
um yes at YouTube specifically so last
year they hired a dedicated uh podcast
somebody from another company to lead up
Podcast they invested five hundred
thousand dollars in shows they secured
NPR to launch a bunch of shows and turn
them into video versions onto and they
were video versions before uh correct
and they launched youtube.com forward
slash podcasts plural that's a URL
listeners could go to just to see that
there's now kind of a page like the
Apple podcast homepage with banners on
it of shows that are being highlighted
and different curated clusters of types
of shows around different subject matter
so in other words if I'm on YouTube and
I go to forward slash podcasts I'm going
to see a kind of a different home page
yes where I'm gonna where normally my
YouTube algorithm is just like feeding
me like oh you one time watched a video
of this and we think you might watch
this now it's going to show me different
things it's like these are things you're
going to want to listen to but they're
also video yep and it's and if you go
there you'd see maybe Dave Ramsey
talking about personal finance and you
may see
um even shows like Phil DeFranco which
is a news show that's kind of a guy that
tries to kind of play neutral on both
sides and you're like okay yeah that is
a podcast you can't you could consume
that audio Wise It's a video it's been
kind of more of a YouTuber but so a lot
of that is all happening but a lot of
new news just dropped which is the
actual functionality of
podcasts on YouTube and what it is is
that you actually can upload a podcast
optimize it with a square image so like
even just show art show art okay and you
can also attribute you can set a
playlist a YouTube playlist as a podcast
and when you do when you optimize
content properly on YouTube to be a
podcast there's now three new
discoverability options and we don't
know how good these are going to be but
this would be that new opportunity
that's just happening right now okay
there's going to be a badge that says
that this is a podcast okay there's
going to be a couple distribution
channels that are like new traffic
sources in the YouTube world of search
and discoverability for people that show
an interest in podcasts and maybe we
want to check others out wow but not a
lot of people are very fast moving when
it comes to optimizing their content
properly to tap into these features but
here's where it gets really interesting
when you do so coming down the road very
soon is your video podcast being
distributed as audio on YouTube music oh
wow and the platform Wars are YouTube
music versus Spotify versus Apple iTunes
because you have music you have podcasts
so these are all these different
ecosystems where YouTube's trying to
take the whole pie yeah they're trying
to have the video Side YouTube music if
you're a YouTube premium user some
people might be a Spotify Premium user
on iTunes premium music or whatever
Apple music and so you pay 10 bucks a
month 12 bucks a month you now have ad
free YouTube videos but you have all
your music on YouTube music just like
Spotify and podcasts now but what are we
let's talk about monetization YouTube
wait a second I want to back you up for
just a second uh you said the ad free so
are the podcasts going to be ad-free
well they could be but also you could go
to YouTube music with ads on just like
you go to Spotify with ads on okay and
so besides your own ads or sponsored
things that you're integrating yeah what
happens when YouTube and Google's
incredibly robust selling to advertisers
starts to put ads on in those podcasts
that also could be dynamic mid Midstream
just like these other platforms do so
one thing is for sure these huge Brands
meta Google who owns YouTube Spotify
they're not like playing kind they're
not like oh let's be nice like they're
trying to take market share and so
YouTube the platform itself should not
be ignored and therefore the opportunity
is to really lean into this